bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
de bergson henri bergson
c'est de la fin du 19e et du début du
20e siècle c'est un philosophe qui s'est
intéressé à de très nombreux sujets
parmi lesquels la conscience le rire la
science bergson se montrait extrêmement
critique envers ce qu'on appelle le
scientisme c'est à dire la tendance à
expliquer tous les phénomènes du monde à
travers le seul prisme de la démarche
scientifique et dans cette vidéo on va
se pencher sur un concept vis-à-vis
duquel la science rencontre une limite
ce concept c'est le temps le temps est
un concept philosophique
particulièrement complexe je dirais même
d'autant plus complexe qui nous paraît
simple qui nous paraît évident mais ce
sont souvent les évidences qui sont les
choses les plus difficiles à formuler
le temps fait partie notre réalité fait
partie de notre quotidien
il suffit d'observer une horloge il
suffit d'ouvrir un agenda
il suffit de constater les effets du
temps sur nous mêmes sur les autres à
travers par exemple le processus du
vieillissement pour se rendre compte que
le temps existe bel et bien et le simple
fait de se poser la question de
l'existence du temps pourrait passer aux
yeux de certaines personnes comme une
pure aberration
et pourtant lorsqu'on se penche sur ce
concept et lorsque l'on tente de le
définir
c'est à dire d'expliquer ce qu'est le
temps est bien très vite on s'aperçoit
qu'il y à d'immenses difficultés c'est
la difficulté que soulevait
saint-augustin lorsqu'il disait qu'est
ce que le temps si personne ne me pose
la question je le sais mais si on me le
demande je l'ignorent
effectivement la difficulté que pointe
saint-augustin si le fait qu'on ne peut
pas expliquer le temps autrement qu'avec
des concepts qui sous-entendent déjà une
compréhension de ce que le temps par
exemple si vous décidez de définir le
temps à travers la notion d'évolution
le temps c'est ce qui fait évoluer les
choses c'est ce qui les fait changer et
bien le concept même d'évolution
présuppose que l'on sache déjà ce qu'est
le temps si vous préférez
il n'existe pas d'autre manière de
définir le temps que par lui même et sa
d'un produit philosophique évidemment ce
n'est pas envisageable
alors après avoir pointé cette extrême
difficulté à définir ce qu'est le temps
saint-augustin a quand même proposé une
tentative et sa tentative consiste à
dire que le temps c'est la division
entre le passé le présent et le futur
passé présent futur sont en quelque
sorte les trois aspects les trois
facettes du temps tel qu'on le vit telle
qu'on expérimente mais l'ennui c'est que
une fois qu'on a dit ça
est-ce qu'on a réellement avancer est-ce
qu'on a réellement progresser dans la
connaissance de ce qu'est le temps eh
bien non pourquoi parce que comme le dit
saint augustin le passé n'existe pas
quand saint-auguste indique le passé
n'existe pas il veut dire par là qu'ils
n'existent plus
par définition ce qui est passé est
dépassé ce qui est passé ne fait plus
partie du monde autrement que sous la
forme du souvenir ou de la trace le
passé n'existe pas car il est révolu le
futur n'existe pas
le futur n'existe pas encore donc là
aussi on peut dire que le futur ne fait
pas partie de notre réalité autrement
que sous la forme d'une projection une
projection mentale
une projection imaginaire mais le fait
est que tout ce que nous vivons
on le vit toujours au présent tout ce
que vous vivez vous le vivez au présent
ce qui fait partie de votre passé
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qui n'a
plus de réalité
si ce n'est la réalité du souvenir mais
au moment où vous l'avez vécu c'était du
présent ce qui appartient au futur
c'est à dire tout ce qu'il vous reste à
expérimenter par rapport à maintenant
c'est dans votre futur
mais lorsque cela arrivera ce sera votre
présent si bien qu'il est possible de
dire que si le passé n'existe plus et
que le futur n'existe pas encore une
reste que le présent alors pourquoi
cette réponse
postel problème et bien justement parce
que l inverse il est tout aussi possible
de dire que le présent n'existe pas
pourquoi est ce qu'il est possible de
dire que le présent n'existe pas parce
que par définition tout ce qui arrive au
présent aussitôt qu'il surgit aussitôt
il se produit fait déjà partie du passé
le présent à quelque chose
d'insaisissable le présent quelque chose
que l'on ne peut pas capturé car
aussitôt qu'on le capture on le relègue
au passé dès lors que vous allez
chercher à immobiliser l'instant présent
à le figer dans le temps cet instant
présent fait déjà partie du passé
donc on se retrouve avec ce paradoxe
insurmontable qui consiste à dire que le
passé et le futur n'existe pas et que le
présent n'existe pas non plus et là on
est très embêté on est très embêté parce
que ça revient à dire que le temps lui
même n'existe pas voyez l'extrême
difficulté de ce concept c'est pas
simplement un effet de manche rhétorique
qui consiste à s'amuser avec la
définition des mots c'est beaucoup plus
profond que ça le temps est un concept
qui ne se laisse pas saisir qui ne se
laisse pas apprivoiser en même temps
qu'il est la plus fondamentale est la
plus immédiate des certitudes
quotidienne
donc que faire face à ce paradoxe que
faire face à cette étanchéité du concept
de temps et bien c'est là qu'on va
pouvoir convoquer henri bergson et voir
de manière un peu plus approfondie ce
qu'il nous propose
pour comprendre la conception
bergsonienne du temps il faut déjà
partir de la distinction qu'il opère
entre deux types de temps et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que bergson suggère
que l'on fasse la différence entre le
temps et la durée le temps dont parle
bergson c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler
le temps physique
qu'est ce que c'est que le temps
physique c'est une unité de mesure dont
on se sert pour placer les événements
les uns par rapport aux autres
selon le système international le temps
se divisent de manière universelle en
seconde en minute en heures chacune de
ces unités est en elle même un
fractionnement de l'unité supérieure
donc un jour ces 24 heures une heure
c'est 60 minutes une minute c'est 60
secondes
d'ailleurs ce système de calcul en base
60 est extrêmement ancien hein ça date
des babyloniens et donc c'est ça le
temps physique c'est-à-dire la division
du temps en unité de mesure objective
qu'est ce que ça veut dire en unité de
mesure objective là ça veut dire tout
simplement que une minute pour moi c'est
une minute pour vous c'est une minute
pour tout le monde pour tout être humain
qui vit sur terre
donc il n'ya pas de différence entre ma
minute et votre minutes et d'ailleurs
heureusement parce que s'il en allait
ainsi ce serait très difficile de
prendre rendez vous on passerait notre
vie à se rater les uns les autres
si nos montres n'était pas raccordée au
même système de mesure si une secondes
s'écoulaient plus lentement pour vous
que pour moi ce serait tout simplement
impossible de vivre
donc on est bien d'accord que ce temps
physique dont on est en train de parler
il est exactement le même pour tout le
monde
il ne dépend pas de votre perception ne
dépend pas de votre bon vouloir
c'est une donnée physique objective
d'ailleurs il faut quand même rappeler
ce que vous savez déjà sans doute à
savoir que les unités de mesure du temps
que nous utilisons elles ne sont pas
totalement arbitraire par exemple
qu'est-ce qu'une année bat une année
vous allez me dire c'est 365 jours oui
mais à quoi ça correspond une année bien
une année c'est le temps que met la
terre pour effectuer sa révolution
autour du soleil
donc on est bien d'accord que l'année
c'est une unité de mesure qui n'a pas
été créée par l'esprit main mais qui se
rapporte à un phénomène physique à un
cycle physique de la même façon la
journée 24 heures c'est le temps que met
la terre pour effectuer sa rotation
donc là encore on est dans une
une mesure qui a une origine physique
une origine naturelle donc de ce qu'on
vit là il est possible de dire que une
année une journée ce sont des unités de
mesure du temps objective il en va
différemment des heures et des minutes
puisque après tout pourquoi diviser une
journée en 24 heures pourquoi est ce
qu'on ne diviseraient pas en 20 heures
ou en trente heures dans ce cas-là ça
viendrait modifier la durée d'une heure
où la durée d'une minute
mais après tout ce serait totalement
possible et si on vivait dans un autre
système de mesure du temps on y verrait
aucun problème donc voilà ce qu'est le
temps physique c'est-à-dire la division
du temps en unités de mesures physiques
et objective en unité de mesure qui ne
dépend pas de la perception que nous
avons personnellement du temps qui passe
sauf que bergson identifie deux
problèmes dans cette conception du temps
le premier problème c'est que cette
représentation du temps représentation
du temps en succession d'instants
puisque les seconds succès de seconde
cette conception du temps ne tient pas
compte de la nature profonde du temps
qui est de s'écouler de manière continue
qu'est ce que ça veut dire que le temps
s'écoule de manière continue ça veut
dire que lorsque vous regardez une
horloge avec la trotteuse qui fait
défiler les seconds
en réalité vous ne voyez pas les
secondes s'écoulent était lequel
s'écoule dans la réalité le mouvement de
l'éguille et saccadé comme si finalement
on passait d'une seconde à l'autre de
manière instantanée
ce qui n'a aucun sens puisque la seconde
c'est l'intervalle de temps entre le
début et la fin d'une seconde le temps
qui s'écoule
ce n'est pas une seconde suivie d'une
autre secondes le temps qui s'écoule
c'est ce qui se passe durant la seconde
c'est ce qui se passe entre les deux
bornes de l'intervalle que constitue une
seconde et l'âge employer le mot
intervalle que je vais vous demander de
garder à l'esprit parce que c'est ainsi
que nous nous représentons
habituellement le temps sous la forme
d'intervalle et effectivement ça se
tient
le temps c'est une succession
d'intervalle mais il faut bien
comprendre que ce qu'on appelle le temps
ce ne sont pas les deux bords de
l'intervalle
mais bien le mouvement qui se produit à
l'intérieur d'un intervalle d'ailleurs
si certains d'entre vous ont déjà
observé une horloge en continu
c'est-à-dire une horloge dont la
trotteuse ne fait pas de mouvements
saccadés né au contraire un mouvement
continu
vous allez voir à quel point c'est
perturbant à quel point c'est
déstabilisant pour nous qui avons
l'habitude de voir les seconds se
succédaient les unes derrière les autres
déjà ça va vous donner l'impression que
le temps s'écoule beaucoup plus vite
lorsque l'aiguillé tourne en continu et
surtout vous allez avoir l'impression
que le temps lui même est modifié en
fait le temps va vous paraître modifier
parce qu'à ce moment là vous aurez sous
les yeux un outil de mesure qui
correspond à la nature réelle du temps
qui correspond à sa nature véritable
c'est-à-dire un écoulement continu
nous avons l'habitude de segmenter le
temps nous avons l'habitude de le
diviser de le compartimenté et ça selon
bergson c'est une erreur quand je dis
que c'est une erreur c'est que quand on
fait ça on dénature le temps on déforme
le temps le temps n'est pas une
succession de segments qu'on aligne les
uns derrière les autres
le temps ne fait pas de saut il s'écoule
en continu donc ça c'est vraiment le
premier problème que bergson identifie
dans notre représentation habituelle du
temps
c'est cette tendance que nous avons à le
segmenter à le découper en intervalles
et à ne représenter que sous la forme de
saut d'une seconde à l'autre d'une
minute à l'autre
alors qu'en réalité le temps ne passe
pas d'une seconde à l'autre le temps est
totalement indifférent aux unités de
mesure qu'on utilise pour le représenter
le temps n'attend pas que la minute soit
terminé pour passer à la minute suivante
il est toujours en train de s'écouler
et c'est cette nature profondément
continue du temps qui selon bergson rend
notre représentation du temps inadéquate
alors sa petite parenthèse pour bergson
cette manière que nous avons de diviser
le temps elle n'est pas totalement
absurde et elle est même tout à fait
logique quand on comprend la manière
dont fonctionne l'esprit humain puisque
personne ne nous dit que il est dans la
nature de l'esprit humain de découper la
réalité
de segmenter le réel pour pouvoir se
l'approprier qu'est ce que ça veut dire
segmenter le réel et bien c'est ce
qu'ont fait par exemple à travers le
langage à travers le langage on segmente
le réel par exemple lorsque j'emploie le
mot arbres je fige dans un mot une
réalité à la fois plurielle et continue
lorsque je prononce le mot arbres vous
avez tous dans votre imagination vous
avez tous dans votre esprit une image
qui peut se former d'un arbre mais sauf
que cet arbre qui se forme dans votre
imagination
on est bien d'accord qu'il n'existe pas
il n'existe pas ailleurs que dans votre
imagination
c'est ce qu'on pourrait appeler un
archétype est pourquoi est-ce que vous
avez cet archétype dans l'esprit mais
tout simplement parce qu'il vous est
impossible de vous représenter tous les
arbres qui existe qui ont existé et qui
existeront donc le concept même d'arbres
est un artifice c'est un artifice de
l'esprit ce qui veut dire que lorsque
vous employer le mot arbres bien vous
parlez en réalité de quelque chose qui
n'existe pas à proprement parler le mot
arbres c'est une construction
intellectuelle qui a pour fonction de
rassembler et de figer tous les arbres
qui existent afin de pouvoir échanger
afin de pouvoir communiquer avec les
autres donc selon bergson le mot le
langage répond d'abord à une nécessité
pratique qui est la nécessité de pouvoir
communiquer avec les autres c'est la
raison pour laquelle bergson reconnaît
qu'il est tout à fait utile de segmenter
la réalité pour pouvoir la comprendre il
faut bien fixer la réalité dans des mots
pour pouvoir échanger pour pouvoir
partager à propos de cette réalité bien
la même façon c'est ce que nous faisons
avec le temps lorsque nous disons
l'année prochaine lorsque nous disons
avant-hier
lorsque nous disons dans trois heures
c'est un moyen pour nous de nous repérer
et de communiquer ses repères à l'autre
et à partir du moment où nous sommes
d'accord sur le système de mesure de ses
repères mais à ce moment là il devient
possible de vivre ensemble mais de la
même façon que le mot dénature la
réalité la représentation du temps sous
la forme de succession d'intervalle est
également une dénaturation de ce qu'est
le temps donc
axxon critique ici c'est ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la mathématisation du
temps la mathématisation du temps c'est
à dire la représentation du temps sous
la forme de segments sous la forme
d'intervalle
c'est à dire des notions de nature
mathématiques qui ne correspond pas à la
nature du réel qui est d'être en
mouvement continu et d'ailleurs cette
mathématisation du temps est également
en même temps une spatialisation du
temps ce n'est pas un hasard si
lorsqu'on veut représenter l'histoire on
utilise l'image de la flèche la flèche
c'est la représentation spatiale du
temps qui s'écoule et de la même façon
que la terre effectue un mouvement
circulaire autour du soleil lorsqu'elle
fait sa révolution
de la même façon l'aiguillé de l'horloge
effectue un tour complet avant d'entamer
un nouveau cycle
donc vous voyez déjà que notre
conception ordinaire du temps sur
laquelle on on a l'habitude de se
reposer comme étant une évidence comme
étant quelque chose qui ne se discute
pas là c'est déjà soumis à de grandes
difficultés
des difficultés qui ne se limite
d'ailleurs pas à celle qu'on vient
dénoncer car bergson identifié un
deuxième problème avec la représentation
du temps physique le deuxième problème
c'est selon bergson le fait que s'il est
vrai que le temps s'écoule de manière
uniforme pour tout le monde
indifféremment de notre perception
autrement dit que une année reste une
année pour moi pour vous et pour tout le
monde le fait et malgré tout que nous
avons tous une perception individuelle
du temps qui passe qu'est ce que ça veut
dire avoir une perception individuelle
du temps qui passe
eh bien ça veut dire qu'on ne perçoit
pas tous le temps s'écouler à la même
vitesse
alors je vais vous donner l'exemple
classique vous êtes en train d'écouter
cette vidéo si elle vous plaît s'il vous
intéresse vous aurez l'impression que le
temps passe vite et si elle vous ennuie
vous aurez l'impression que le temps
passe très lentement
ça c'est la distinction que bergson
effectué entre le temps objectifs et le
temps subjectif et ce temps subjectif
c'est à dire la perception individuelle
que nous avons du temps qui passe c'est
ça que bergson appelle la durée la durée
pour la distinguer du temps qui est une
mesure objective
là où la durée est une mesure
effective évidemment ce temps subjectif
cette durée nous en faisons tous
l'expérience tout le temps c'est à dire
qu'à chaque fois que nous sommes en
train de passer un moment de plaisir de
joie
là ce moment là c'est comme si le temps
n'existait plus pour nous le temps ne
sera pas pour nous ici un objet de
conscience un objet de pensée
quand on pense au temps qui s'écoule
sait déjà qu'on n'est pas concentré sur
ce qu'on fait et donc il ya de fortes
chances qu'à ce moment là le temps nous
paraissent s'écouler lentement alors
qu'au contraire lorsque nous sommes en
immersion dans ce que nous faisons
à ce moment là le temps n'existe plus
pour nous c'est pas que le temps est
passé plus vite puisque pour les autres
il s'est écoulé à la même vitesse
c'est simplement que notre perception du
temps a été altéré par la manière dont
nous étions impliqués dans ce que nous
faisons c'est pour ça que le meilleur
moyen de lutter contre l'ennui c'est de
faire un exercice de focalisation
c'est-à-dire de concentration soutenue
sur chaque détail qui se présentent à
vous ça c'est quelque chose que je vous
encourage vraiment à faire quand vous
vous ennuyez partez à la chasse au
détail et des vous voyez un détail
essayer de faire un zoom sur lui vous
allez voir à ce moment là que tout
devient intéressant et c'est comme ça
qu'on conjure l'ennui en trouvant un
objet sur lequel soutenir notre
attention
donc cette conception du temps cette
conception subjectif du temps que
bergson appelle la durée on peut dire
qu'elle n'a strictement rien à voir avec
la conception objectifs du temps une
soirée avec votre bien-aimé n'équivaut
pas à une soirée en réunion avec votre
patron
on est bien d'accord après ça dépend de
ce que vous faites avec votre patron
vous comprenez l'idée ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que pour berck sonne
il est philosophiquement fautif de ne
pas opérer cette distinction entre le
temps objectifs et le temps subjectif
c'est philosophiquement fautif
parce que ça revient à nier une
composante essentielle du temps et cette
composante c'est la perception pour
bergson la durée est une affaire de
perception et même si
la perception a besoin d'un objet
apercevoir c'est à dire même si la
perception que l'on a du temps ne peut
pas être totalement séparée du temps
objectif en réalité la perception que
nous avons du temps à une valeur
beaucoup plus importante que le temps
lui-même ne faut pas oublier que tout ce
que vous vivez relève toujours de votre
perception
quand vous dites à votre enfant qu'il
aura un cadeau si les sages le 25
décembre et que le 25 décembre cédant 4
mois et je peux vous dire que ces quatre
mois vont lui paraître extrêmement long
ça va lui paraître extrêmement l'ont
déjà parce que vous aurez fait naître
chez lui l'impatience et que
l'impatience c'est précisément une
perception est tirée du temps et aussi
parce que l'enfant parce qu'il a vécu
moins d'années que vous n'a pas le même
rapport à la temporalité
un enfant de 8 ans pour lui un an
c'est un huitième de son existence alors
que si vous en avez 40 il ya un 40e de
votre existence
ça paraît assez court donc c'est ça que
je veux dire quand je parle du caractère
relatif du temps c'est à dire le fait
que la perception que l'on a du temps va
dépendre de facteurs qui ne sont pas
directement liées au temps comme
phénomène
objectif donc pour résumer ce qu'on a
dit depuis le début de cette vidéo on
est parti du fait que le temps était un
objet philosophique extrêmement complexe
et difficile à définir et pour éclairer
ce concept bergson propose de distinguer
le temps objectif c'est-à-dire une
représentation physique mathématique et
spatial du temps et ce tant physiques se
distingue de ce que bergson appelle la
durée qu'on pourrait appeler le temps
psychologique tant psychologique qui est
d'abord un phénomène lié à notre
perception
alors on avance un peu dans la
conception bergsonienne du temps on va
introduire ne sont très importantes pour
préciser ce qu'est la nature du temps ou
en tout cas du temps perçu du temps dont
nous faisons l'expérience de manière
subjective c'est la notion de mémoire
vous souvenez au début de cette vidéo je
disais que selon saint-augustin le passé
n'existe pas et j'ai ajouté le passé
n'existe pas autrement que sous la forme
du souvenir ou de la trace du souvenir
ou de la trace c'est à dire que
exemple si vous faites une tache de vin
sur votre chemise blanche bien la tâche
va vous rappeler que par le passé vous
avez fait couler du vin sur votre
chemise la tâche va venir représenter la
trace de cet événement passé et donc
cette trace elle se perpétue elle-même
dans le temps la trace c'est le
prolongement de l'événement passé dans
le temps de la même façon le souvenir
c'est le prolongement de l'expérience
passée dans le temps et d'ailleurs vous
remarquerez que on a tendance souvent à
reconstruire les souvenirs très
différemment de la manière dont les
événements se sont produits en réalité
le souvenir n'est jamais une copie de la
réalité le souvenir est toujours une
réécriture de la réalité est souvent le
souvenir va lui-même qu'on portait la
trace de la perception que l'on a eu
d'événement si vous avez eu un événement
traumatisant
il est possible que votre souvenir
mettre l'accent sur ce traumatisme
alors qu'au contraire si vous avez vécu
une situation heureuse de joie de
plaisir intense bien le souvenir va
lui-même être le véhicule de ce plaisir
dans le présent tout ça pour dire que
lorsqu'on dit que le passé n'existe pas
ou qu'il n'existe plus en réalité c'est
pas tout à fait vrai le passé est
toujours là il est toujours là sous la
forme de la trace sous la forme du
souvenir il est toujours là sous la
forme de l'histoire et qu'est ce que
c'est qu'une histoire
et bien c'est l'accumulation
d'expériences dans le passé qui conduit
à la réalité présente
nous sommes tous le produit d'une
histoire ce que vous êtes maintenant ce
que vous êtes aujourd'hui c'est le
produit c'est le résultat de tout ce que
vous avez vécu dans votre passé donc une
certaine manière nous devrions tous
remercier notre passé pour avoir fait de
nous ce que nous sommes
parce que sans ce passé nous ne serions
pas ce que nous sommes nous serions
quelqu'un d'autre don de sang
villa est toujours à travers la notion
de mémoire il est possible de dire que
le temps c'est la conservation du passé
dans le présent conservation du passé
dans le présent on pourrait dire
conservation du passage dans le présent
parce que le temps c'est d'abord un
passage
c'est le phénomène par lequel on passe
d'une situation à l'autre et que vient
faire la mémoire là dedans
eh bien elle vient rassemblés dans notre
esprit les différents moments de notre
révolution qui a conduit à ce que nous
sommes dans le présent
si tout à coup vous perdez toute mémoire
vous ne saurez plus qui vous êtes vous
aurez oublié jusqu'à votre propre
identité jusqu'à votre propre nom parce
que c'est la conservation grâce à la
mémoire de tout ce que vous avez vécu
qui vous permet de savoir qui vous êtes
on ne sait pas qu'il en ait si l'on n'a
pas la mémoire de ce que l'on a vécu
donc de ce point de vue là la mémoire
c'est le ciment de notre conscience de
soi
s'il n'y a pas de mémoire il n'y a pas
de conscience de soi
et s'il n'y a pas de conscience de soi
il n'y a pas d'identité
donc nous sommes ce que nous sommes
grâce à la mémoire grâce à la mémoire et
donc à la mémorisation de ce que nous
avons vécu et en même temps et vous
allez voir que c'est un nouveau paradoxe
si le temps est intimement liée à la
notion de conservation il est tout
autant liée à la notion de
transformation
pourquoi parce que le temps c'est la
condition pour que nous puissions
évoluer le temps c'est ce qui nous
permet de changer
comment pourrait-on changer sans en
avoir le temps ce serait comme vouloir
se nourrir sans avoir le droit de manger
c'est compliqué
le changement présuppose le temps
précisément parce que le temps c'est une
puissance de transformation pour
l'illustrer je prendre un exemple
extrêmement simple que vous avez tous
déjà vu c'est vous savez ce qu'on
appelle les avants après on prend deux
images on les met côte à côte et on
observe les différences on observe les
changements qui se sont opérés d'une
image à l'autre
alors on retrouve beaucoup ça dans les
défis sportifs notamment musculation
puis on regarde les deux images on se
dit mais il ya eu une transformation
radicale entre les deux moments mais
qu'est ce qui a permis cette
transformation qu'est ce qui a permis
cette métamorphose
et bien c'est le temps finalement ce qui
est sans doute le plus important dans ce
avant après c'est précisément ce qu'on
ne voit pas c'est à dire ce qu'il y a
entre la première photo est la deuxième
photo on montre le avant et le après
alors même que ce qui a rendu possible
cette transformation radicale ne nous
est pas montrée c'est bien le temps
entre les deux photos qui a permis
d'obtenir la transformation qu'on a sous
les yeux
et pourtant c'est la seule chose qu'on
ne voit pas c'est amusant c'est amusant
que pour illustrer ce que sont les
effets du temps on nous montre tout sauf
le temps qui a fait son oeuvre
autrement dit pour illustrer le temps on
nous montre les effets du temps
et quels sont les effets du temps c'est
le changement c'est l'évolution c'est la
transformation est un morceau ce qui
peut être rapide qui peut être lente qui
peut être continu ou discontinu qui peut
être régulière ou irrégulière mais dans
tous les cas le temps ne se matérialise
dans la conscience que sous la forme du
changement le temps ne nous est pas
dévoiler à travers ce qu'il est dans sa
nature
le temps nous est représentée à travers
les deux extrémités de l'intervalle à
l'intérieur duquel il s'écoule donc si
le temps existe bel et bien
si le temps est effectivement une
réalité il l'est d'abord en tant que
puissance de transformation il l'est
d'abord en tant que condition de la
métamorphose
et finalement on retiendra de ce que
nous dit bergson que le temps c'est
aussi et surtout ce que nous en faisons
le temps est d'abord ce que nous en
faisons
si vous n'en faites rien si vous restez
assis que vous attendez que le temps
passe il ya des chances pour que ce
temps vous paraissent très long il ya
des chances pour que vous sans briller
dans l'ennui
il ya aussi des chances pour que
souvenir que vous aurez de votre passé
ne soit pas de nature à vous aider à
vous projeter dans l'avenir
al'inverse si pour vous chaque secondes
qui s'écoulent est une nouvelle occasion
occasion d'évoluer occasion de vivre là
ce moment là le temps ne sera plus votre
adversaire
comme dit baudelaire mais il deviendra à
votre allié il deviendra votre bien le
plus précieux et si l'écoulement continu
du temps et pour vous une source
d'angoissé si vous aimeriez détenir la
télécommande qui permettrait de mettre
le temps en pause bien dites vous que
lorsque le temps est en pause
nous n'existons plus car nous ne sommes
plus là pour assister au spectacle de la
métamorphose
nous ne sommes plus là pour assister à
ce qui constitue l'âme de la réalité qui
est cette transformation permanente dont
nous faisons partie et à laquelle nous
participons et c'est parce que le temps
nous est compté
c'est parce que le temps ne nous attend
pas qu'il est de notre devoir de faire
vivre le temps je vous remercie
[Musique]
et
ans
où